مشكلة الوقود هذه
[موسيقى]
هذا الشخص
الملاحظة
[موسيقى]
مثل بصمة الخبز
شيء يحدث أثناء تغير الطقس
الماء يتغير الملح يتغير
حالتك المزاجية تتغير ، سأقطعها
فيه زيت زيتون فيه اولي ولد
جبنه
لقد كنت في الفرن
في الفرن مع والدتي
أبي يريد نقوداً أمي عجينة أبي
أنا سيد الأعمال
نفعل ذلك في عطلات نهاية الأسبوع
[موسيقى]
أي في النقطة التي لا يخرج فيها خبزنا جيدًا.
لذلك خبزنا ليس ما نريد
في هذه المرحلة لا شيء مهم
لأن الأهم
لهذا السبب نعرف الكثير عن الخبز
أنا أحب كثيرا إن لم يكن لي
لا خبز
[موسيقى]
يفتح باليد مما يجعله أرق
فتحت ، هذه هي المعجنات
[موسيقى]
هذا ايضا
الكركم والجوز
[موسيقى]
لم يكن لدينا مثل هذه الثقافة العظيمة
هذه هي كيفية إخبارها ، لتعيشها
أفضل خبز في عالمنا
هذا هو فرقنا الكبير في الواقع.
إنتاج شيء جديد
لا يعلم هكذا كان في الماضي
نحن بحاجة للكشف عن كنزنا
[موسيقى]